[Music]
during the pandemic 23 million american
households adopted a pet
but now that owners are leaving animals
home alone to go back to work are pets
stressing out
what we found across the pandemic was
that for dogs and cats separation
anxiety increased significantly for dogs
it increased by about 33
for cats the increase was double so
twice as many cats diagnosed with
anxiety so they absolutely sense the
changes in our households as a chief
medical officer of banfield pet hospital
dr mcallister draws insights from data
collected over nine and a half million
pet visits in 2021 from 1 000 hospitals
across america when we start leaving the
house for that full day of work that 8
10 12 hour day of being gone it's a big
routine disruption and so we need to
start preparing them so that they can
navigate it with success
let's walk through some specific tips
and strategies pet owners can use to
deal with pet separation anxiety
if they're experiencing some anxiety
being calm and cool and collected with
those goodbyes and greetings is the most
important thing to do so we can practice
leaving our dogs leaving our pets for
progressively longer periods of time
start with leaving your pet in the room
alone and going to another room in the
house for a few minutes and then
returning you can slowly expand that
time so the next time you might leave to
go to the grocery store and be gone for
15 or 20 minutes and then come back
again helping them realize that
everything was okay you came back you
didn't make a big deal about it and so
they don't need to make a big deal about
it and so we start easing our way into
that long day rather than just suddenly
hitting them with us being gone and them
not knowing what happened
so some people will give their dog a
favorite treat for example a toy to help
distract them as they leave to help take
their mind off of it that idea of
associating a food treat with the
departure can be a way to make it more
positive what we do have to be careful
of is that those treats can get pretty
calorie dense and then very importantly
when we come home it's okay to just kind
of ignore them for a little while and
let them settle down before we give them
the greeting that we really are looking
forward to a couple of other things we
can do behaviorally is to really just
set up a better routine so that they
know what to expect at various times in
the day they know when we leave they
know when we come home they know when
walk time is they know when food time is
so routine is very important for our
pets
so exercise before you leave is always a
great way to kind of burn off the the
willies for them to then head into that
day where they might just nap instead of
being anxious about your departure walk
time exercise is so important for their
peace of mind for their well-being
particularly in a time of stress for
cats it might be playing with a fishing
pole toy or a ball toss around the house
depending on what they're interested in
but getting them regular exercise is a
great way to help their brains be calmer
during those times of stress once we
leave them home alone how do we keep
tabs on them throughout the day
[Music]
a lot of people will put some sort of a
pet cam in their house so that they can
see what their pet's doing during the
day some of those even allow you to talk
to your pet or to dispense a treat at a
certain time and those can be great for
the pet that's engaged in that type of
behavior that will engage with the
screen now jack when i try to facetime
with him he pretty much ignores me so
for him you know it would be more about
just watching what's going on during the
day is he jumping up on the counter is
he destroying something is he anxious
when i leave how does a pet stress
manifest itself at home cats tend to
hide their stress and hide their anxiety
and so what you might see is a cat
that's more withdrawn a cat that spends
more time hiding under the bat or a cat
who starts expressing their displeasure
and their stress with litter box changes
and what about dogs it might be
increased panting or pacing it might be
behaviors that you don't actually get to
see because they express them when
you're not at home so your neighbors
might report that your dog has started
barking a lot more you might notice that
a dog who normally was okay being left
alone is now starting to be destructive
you might see that there's some soiling
in the house maybe your dog has never
done before are they pacing a lot are
they sleeping as much as they normally
do or excessively are they scratching or
barking a lot there's also a growing
market for fitbit style monitors that
give owners a peek into the secret life
of their dogs monitoring red flags such
as over scratching licking and sleeping
and changing eating patterns
there's a variety of nutrients that have
been associated with having a calming
effect some of them are milk proteins
old tryptophan which you might recognize
from you know turkey dinner through
various research studies we know that
these can have a calming effect on dogs
and cats so many of these supplements
are going to help to kind of take the
edge off but they may not be the
cure-all for a pet with really severe
separation anxiety so in addition to
nutrients that your pet can ingest the
use of pheromones is becoming more and
more popular so we can use pheromones
from both dogs and cats and they come in
the form of collars that your pet can
wear they can be sprays that you can put
on a bandana that you put around your
pet's neck or you put them in their
crate or on their bed they also make
diffusers that you plug into the wall
that emit that pheromone throughout the
day so for dogs it's a pheromone called
the milk appeasing pheromone it's a
pheromone that the mother dog gives off
as she's nursing her puppies for cats
it's a slightly different pheromone but
it's still that same idea of giving them
a greater sense of calm in a time of
stress
banfield did a survey in 2020 of pet
owners and we found that 57
indicated that when they returned to
work they would want to return in a
situation that would enable them to take
their pet and the good news is that we
also did a survey of ceos and found that
one in two or fifty percent of ceos said
that they plan to institute some sort of
way for people to return to work with
their pets after the pandemic ended in
addition a recent study by the american
animal hospital association found that
90 of employees in pet friendly
workplaces versus 65 percent of
employees in non-pet friendly jobs feel
fully engaged with their work and are
willing to recommend their employer to
others pets provide us with some amazing
support and comfort and the human animal
bond is undeniable throughout the world
so making sure that we consider their
uniqueness and that we do our very best
to
create a life with mutual benefit and
they get to experience that consistency
the stability and the support of the
people who love them the families that
they belong to
[Music]